[Music]
on this wednesday night mounting
casualties from the heatwave
in the west this is a natural disaster
the spike in heat related deaths the
questions about why the vulnerable
weren't protected
plus the rise in wildfires and the
canadian climate scientist who says this
extreme weather
is the new reality 182 more
unmarked graves another devastating
discovery
at a former residential school the whole
system of residential schools was a
genocide plus canadian radio stations
amplifying indigenous voices and he's a
free man again
why bill cosby's sex assault conviction
was thrown out
national with donna friesen
[Music]
oh that's hot that's hot
this narrow escape from a wildfire
happened in bc's interior near
lillauet the region caught in
record-setting high temperatures
the driver did manage to get to safety
but the tinder dry
forests are ripe for more dangerous
fires after days of record-breaking heat
almost all of bc is now under high or
extreme fire danger
those kinds of conditions in june are
extremely unusual
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is still no relief tonight for
much of western canada
heat warnings remain in place for most
of bc all of alberta
all of saskatchewan and most of manitoba
it's forecast to hit
41 in litton bc today not another
record-breaking day but still scorching
in alberta fort mcmurray was expected to
hit 41 as well
while saskatoon is forecast to reach 34.
in southern bc a place not accustomed to
such prolonged heat the toll is growing
by the day
according to bc's chief coroner at least
486 sudden deaths were reported
in the last five days that's a 195
percent increase in reports usually
there are about 165
sudden deaths reported in that time
frame investigations are now underway
but in many cases it's believed heat
was a factor it seems that many
folks didn't realize that
the heat could be deadly and so
getting this information out letting
people in the province know that we've
seen an
unprecedented number of deaths is a a
real
warning to people that that this can be
deadly heat can be deadly
there are those who believe it adds up
to a public health emergency and there
are questions about the premier's
response and why more wasn't done to
protect the vulnerable
robin gill has our top story tonight
at burnaby general hospital it's almost
too much
the staff is taking in so many patients
simply unable to deal with the heat
we've had a lot of people coming in with
heat stroke we're over
overwhelmed with people in the emergency
room we've got people lined up down the
halls
the heat wave has turned deadly for
dozens in the vancouver area
many of them older people living alone
seniors living in these apartments
they are greenhouse they do act a bit as
greenhouses they don't have good
cross ventilation the coroner admits the
province was caught off guard
i think it's very likely that many of us
misunderstood that the extreme risks
you know that that we're not used to
this heat
in retrospect we'll be looking at what
we can do differently to prevent similar
deaths in the future
at no point did british columbia declare
a heat emergency
fatalities are part of life the public
was acutely aware that we had a heat
problem
and we were doing our best to break
through all of the other noise to
encourage people to take steps to
protect themselves
after there was outrage john horgan
backtracked with a tweet
morning families deserve our compassion
and the wording of my comments didn't
reflect that
the public safety minister is now
reviewing the province's emergency act
so after we're past this we will need to
take a hard look at what we need to
change for the future
ambulances haven't been able to keep up
with calls for heat-related incidents
this former bc paramedic says the
province had its head in the sand
dealing with this emergency this is a
natural disaster what's happened
temperatures in vancouver are
unprecedented
and obviously the numbers are coming out
now people have died
more criticism against the province
coming from a former health minister
i would argue that this heat wave is a
public health emergency and should have
been declared as such and we we could
have done more to
put i think some precautions in place
bc's advocate for seniors is asking
whether there could have been a warning
system in place
but even that may not have been enough
to keep those who didn't recognize the
danger
until it was too late we just are
unaware of how
quickly the impact of the heat
has overtaken them temperatures have
diminished in coastal bc
as the heat dome moves east over the
interior and much of alberta and
saskatchewan
but this is just june there are many
more sweltering summer days ahead
robin gill global news vancouver
a little later i'll speak with one of
the world's top communicators about
climate change canadian scientist
catherine hey ho
talks about why it's taken some people
so long to recognize the danger
we are in
this is what's left of the century-old
catholic church in morenville alberta
bystanders watched as it went up in
flames early this morning
fire crews tried to save it but couldn't
police are treating the fire as
suspicious and are investigating
it is the latest in a string of churches
that have burned to the ground
since the discovery of hundreds of
unmarked graves at former church-run
residential school sites now another
revelation another bc first nation has
announced the discovery of
more unmarked grave sites at a former
residential school
the tuna first nation says ground
penetrating radar
has revealed as many as 182 potential
graves
they were found at a former school in
cranbrook bc that was run by the
catholic church
indigenous leaders are now preparing to
take their demands for an apology
directly to the pope
at the vatican eric sorenson explains
another sad discovery the remains of 182
bodies in
unmarked graves near the former st
eugene's mission school in the
southeastern corner of british columbia
ground penetrating radar made the
disturbing finding last year
believed to be members of the katanaka
nation there are more than 130
residential school sites in canada and
indigenous leaders say
answers must be found at all of them the
focus is
on getting the research done the
investigation done and the proper memory
commemorations done um the whole system
of residential schools was a genocide
meantime the burning of churches has now
spread to the east coast
the most recent a former catholic church
in indian brook nova scotia
home to the sebacanakity first nation in
the last 10 days churches have been
burned in three provinces
bc alberta and nova scotia all but one
are catholic churches that have been
destroyed
since the discovery of unmarked remains
at residential schools
the prime minister condemned the
apparent arson at the churches but
expressed sympathy once more for the
pain
indigenous people and all canadians are
feeling at the discovery of the unmarked
grave sites
the destruction of places of worship is
unacceptable
and it must stop we must work together
to right past wrongs everyone
has the role to play the national chief
of the assembly of first nations was
critical of the church burnings
but also announced that he will visit
the pope in december
hoping that the catholic church will
apologize for its role in running
residential schools
and that the pope will come to canada to
do so in person
we are hopeful that at some point in
time the appropriate words will come
the spirit will move all of this comes
on the eve of canada day
historically a time to celebrate the
country and its founding
but this year a growing number of
canadians find it difficult to celebrate
how this country was founded it's not
inappropriate i don't i don't think at
all
to to stop and look back
at our past as we imagine on canada day
a future we would like to be and would
like to become canadians really want to
see these travesties
dealt with they want to see the proper
reparations made
and so that's an opportunity for them to
use that day to really bring us closer
to what canada says its national values
truly are
there will not be big canada day
celebrations on parliament hill the
pandemic had already seen to that
but this year in particular many
canadians see this july 1st
as a time for a different kind of
reflection about the country
eric sorensen global news toronto
in florida the death toll has risen to
18 in the rubble of that collapsed condo
more than 140 people are still missing
and as jackson proskow reports the
grueling search is taking a toll
on workers
it is slow excruciating work
digging through the rubble by hand
finding only pieces of shattered lives
we find strollers and baby bottles
stuffed toys rescuers found more bodies
overnight
and more faint possibilities that
someone might have survived
deep in a tunnel or void minor chances
but i would not say that there are no
chances
for the dozens of families still waiting
for answers including the relatives of
four missing canadians
it's an agonizing weight though it's
still officially a search and rescue
operation
it's not going to stop and they're going
to they're going to get answers one way
or another
seven days in even experienced rescue
workers are feeling the toll
our own guys are hurting inside i'm sure
robert wells
and bowser are part of the miami-dade
fire department's peer support team
they're here to help fellow first
responders cope with the mental trauma
they suffer on the job
especially the guys that are working on
the pile they're seeing all kinds of
things
there's still no clear indication of
what caused the collapse
engineers are focused on witness reports
like what the building's doorman heard
he heard a muffled boom and then x
number of seconds later a much bigger
boom and then y seconds after that a
much bigger boom
answers could take months accounting for
all the missing could take
weeks in what is now one of the
deadliest structural failures in modern
u.s history
jackson proskow global news surfside
florida
the european union has a new vaccine
passport system which is good news for
millions of people itching to travel
the thing is they must have received
vaccines approved for use in europe
and that excludes many people including
almost 300
000 canadians redmond shannon explains
the european union is gradually rolling
out its
digital covet certificate the program
will allow eu residents who've had
covert 19 or who provide a negative test
to travel more easily the same will
apply to the fully vaccinated
if and when the eu expands those rules
to non-residents
it could be good news for canadian
visitors brussels has approved
the same four vaccines as ottawa however
the eu
has not authorized the indian made
kovi shield version of astrazeneca only
the european made one in canada 272
000 people have received at least one
dose of kobe shield
compared with 1.6 million canadians who
have had the european made astrazeneca
my understanding is that the two
astrazeneca manufactured vaccines
european union and indian
are biologically identical so what we've
got is a bureaucratic
situation here that could well indeed
stand in the way
of people's freedom of travel the
european medicines agency says the maker
of kobe shield
the serum institute of india hasn't
applied for authorization
in europe you do have to go through this
very rigorous
quality control process where you are
assured that the same process was used
and that the vaccine that you have at
the end of your process
is as good as the one that's coming from
another plant that's already
authorized the disconnect highlights a
broader issue
hundreds of millions in the developing
world are getting shots
not approved in the west i think what we
need to do is the world needs to get
together and then they need to have a
list
of vaccines that are approved
across across the standard the eu says
its individual member countries can
also decide to accept travelers
vaccinated with who approved shots
ottawa says it's in talks with the g7
and the who on the issue redmond shannon
global news
london communicating about climate
change coming up why the message doesn't
seem to get through until we're immersed
in extreme weather
the record-breaking heatwave in the west
has made international news and canada
is not the only
country suffering in the heat take a
look at this map from the world
meteorological organization much of the
northern hemisphere is in the midst of
an exceptional
early hot summer from north africa the
arabian peninsula
eastern europe iran and the north
western indian subcontinent
maximum daily temperatures exceeded 45
degrees in
a number of places reaching the 50s in
the sahara
to help understand what's happening
we've reached out to canadian
atmospheric scientist catherine hay ho
she has authored over 100 research
papers written many climate reports and
she teaches at
texas tech university she's also the
chief scientist
for the nature conservancy catherine
thanks so much
for joining us today can we start with
some context
you have said that global temperatures
are rising faster than at any time in
the history of human civilization
why should we look at this latest heat
wave is more than just
a single exceptional weather event well
that is true global temperatures are
rising and temperatures in canada are
rising twice as fast as the rest of the
world
we see this playing out in our monthly
temperatures we are already
breaking high temperatures at the
monthly scale four times more frequently
than low temperature records
but we're also seeing it in how climate
change is loading the weather dice
against us so we always have a chance of
rolling a double six
a heat wave in the summer but decade by
decade
as the planet warms it's sort of like
it's sneaking in and taking one of those
numbers on our dice and turning it into
another six
taking another number and turning it
into a seven and so we're rolling more
sixes and even some sevens today as
climate change
fuels our natural summer weather
patterns i want to ask you about
something that you
tweeted uh i think last week you said
our entire civilization is built on the
assumption that
climate varies within bounds that can be
predicted based on the past you said
it's as if
we've been driving down the road looking
in the rear view mirror but now we've
hit a dangerous curve and our wheels are
teetering off the edge
it's a great analogy why is it taken so
long
to recognize the danger we're in we have
assumed that we can depend on the past
to tell us what the drought of record is
what the average summer winter
temperature is where the
to draw the flood zones we've built our
civilization on that
not just for decades but for centuries
even millennia
yet today climate is changing faster
than any time that we humans have ever
experienced in the course of
civilization as we know it
and that's why we have to take our eyes
off the rear view mirror
we have to look ahead into the future
and incorporate information
on the changes that are already
unavoidable and inevitable into our
planning
while at the same time doing everything
we can to cut our carbon emissions
as much as we can as soon as we can to
avoid the very worst of the impacts
do you think that it's just the nature
of human behavior that unless we endure
something ourselves like this heat wave
in the west we're not
likely to take it seriously we all know
the things that we're supposed to be
doing
but until we get a wake-up call often
many of us are not doing them why
because of something called
psychological distance
we humans see risks as being far off
and with climate change we see
psychological distance
in spades if you ask people across north
america do you think climate is changing
do you think it will affect plants and
animals
so other species not humans do you think
it will affect people who live
in low-income countries on the other
side of the world do you think it will
affect future generations
people say yes but then you say do you
think it will affect
you and the numbers drop precipitously
we just don't see the immediacy of the
impacts until we experience them
ourselves
well scientists have been ringing the
alarm bell for a long time now do you
think they're getting the messaging
right we scientists have been sounding
the alarm for a long time and i think
what we got
wrong was this we just assumed if you
tell people there's a risk
they'll fix it but until people
recognize
number one what it means to everything i
already care about here and now today
and number two what we can do what
viable solutions look like
people remain paralyzed and unable to
act and so that's what we see changing
today
not the scientific message it is still
the same it's real it's us
it's serious and the time to act is now
but we're starting to see people
recognize that the impacts are real
they're here they matter and the
solutions are
also here and actionable today catherine
hey ho thank you so much
for your time thank you for having me
out of prison ahead why bill cosby's sex
assault conviction has been overturned
the man who is one of the architects of
the american war on terror has died
donald rumsfeld who was defense
secretary under former president george
w bush oversaw the invasion
of afghanistan and the overthrow of
saddam hussein in iraq
he claimed iraq had weapons of mass
destruction but
none were ever found the war in iraq
killed hundreds of thousands including
thousands of u.s military members
many historians and military experts
blame rumsfeld for decisions that led to
difficulties in iraq
he was 88 years old bill cosby is a free
man tonight after serving two years of
his sentence for sexual assault a
dramatic reversal in his case
the pennsylvania supreme court ruled
cosby had been denied a fair trial it
found that
a previous district attorney had made a
deal that cosby would not face
prosecution
cosby then went on to testify in a
lawsuit brought by canadian andrea
constand
that deposition was later used as
evidence against him cosby was convicted
in 2018 of three felony counts of
drugging and sexually assaulting
constand
more than 60 other women also came
forward claiming cosby drugged and
assaulted them
over the past five decades
just listen next making sure we hear
indigenous voices
today hundreds of broadcasters across
canada use the airwaves
to amplify indigenous voices the
initiative was called a day to
listen of course we need to spend far
more than just one day listening
but as morgan campbell explains this was
a start to listen to people whose voices
for too long
have been unheard hear the voices of
indigenous people in canada
this is a time for elevating indigenous
voices
opening doors to fresh perspectives
sharing
stories reflecting communities from
people
like bob watts a member of the six
nations reserve
in grand river ontario i think as
it is making us think and act and
consider things
in a way that we never have before
this is why more than 500 stations are
taking part
in a data listen which in partnership
with the gord downey and chaney wenjack
fund
aims to build cultural understanding and
to
create a path toward reconciliation they
force them
to go to the indian restaurant to school
johnny wen jack's story may be familiar
from the late gord downey's music and a
national heritage minute
at nine years old when jack was forced
to attend a residential school in kenora
ontario when he was 12 he escaped in an
effort to reunite with his family
but died a week later today there is a
renewed call to share stories like
wenjack's
a commitment many indigenous canadians
are calling for i think canadians have a
great opportunity to
to take part in correcting the mistakes
of of the past
and why so many are asking for canada
day to become a day of remembrance
and mourning those 215 young people
spirits have woken up
everybody not only in canada but the
world morgan campbell
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
york canada is the peace tower in ottawa
the prime minister says the flag will
remain at half-mast on canada day this
year to honor the indigenous children
who died
at residential schools thanks for
watching i'm off for a few days and
we'll see you here again in early july
[Music]
bye